Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
I'm here in New York City.
Be impressed,
boy.
Talking about second season of F is for family.
I want to thank everybody once again who's been watching it,
tweeting about it,
Instagram and about it.
My space in about his Facebook and whatever the fuck you kids do.
I have no idea.
Um,
I had a long day of press yesterday,
but a great time and a great time.
Did Howard Stern show for the first time in like 15 years?
MMM,
I had a great time on that one.
And then,
uh,
he was funny.
I could barely sleep the night before.
I was just thinking about how much my life has changed in the last 15 years.
Plus I was on,
um,
west coast time plus I was nervous going in there.
You know,
you're going to do that show.
It's like,
oh my God,
what's this guy going to ask me?
And um,
it ended up going great.
Thank God.
You know,
that's one of those ones you leave.
It's like,
did he have a good time?
But it was it all right.
Did I do an all right job?
Um,
I did joke with them that I'll see him again in another 15 years,
but it was obviously fucking awesome to do the show and I had a great time.
I hope you had a good time to and uh,
then of course I did Jimmy and say,
am I did the ob show?
I'm going to try to do,
Anthony showed today.
Um,
I did Ron Ron show.
I did fucking,
uh,
what else did I do?
Barstool sports.
I was everywhere.
I did something for the m and m channel.
I did the trucker show just running my year.
I called in the major major league baseball channel.
Yeah.
And I fucking,
yeah,
for whatever reason decided to talk about the Kevin Durant's rate
on baseball channel.
We totally got into that.
Talk to somebody else on Toronto.
Um,
great game last night,
by the way.
Finally a nice competitive game between the Cavaliers and the warriors before
the former league MVP that they signed.
They hit a fucking dagger three pointer.
Um,
I dunno,
gravy train,
gravy,
train,
jumping on the,
it's a gravy train championship.
That's what I'm going to call it.
Um,
and I've gotten into so many fucking debates.
A lot of people don't agree with me.
A lot of people go well abroad did at Miami saw.
And I keep saying,
I'm not talking about players,
I'm just talking about this as a fan.
Nobody seems to be able to hear me.
So last night I'm in a fucking diner.
Um,
and I get in this fucking debate with this dude.
You know,
one of these young guys,
you know,
they say,
I don't think the Beatles are that good or I think the Beatles overrated.
And always try to tell him like,
you really not going to find any musician with any sort of knowledge of music
that's going to say you're right.
I think why these kids say this,
aside from the fact that it's been so long since the Beatles were around,
that it's hard to go back and see the effect they had on the game.
It's like trying to look back at Johnny Unitas and see how he brought the
quarterback position into the modern era.
How the fuck are you going to do that in 20 high?
He out of these of these goddamn kids going to do it.
I also think the reason why the Beatles get so much shit from people like it
seems like age 38 and under is I think baby boomers are so fucking annoying and
that's all they talk about.
And they act like music ended,
you know,
in 1970 when they broke up.
But,
um,
I was arguing with this guy,
and this is one of the funniest things anybody's ever said.
He basically said that he didn't like the Beatles because when he puts on the
Beatles,
it didn't make them want to get on an elliptical and workout.
That has gotta be one of the funniest fucking things.
And I immediately was just like,
dude,
how many fucking food courts do you sit in at?
Just like,
I don't even know what to say to that.
It's like,
dude,
you know,
everybody likes Mozart,
but you know,
it doesn't make me want to put on my leg warmers and get on the exercise bike.
Um,
but who the fuck am I to say how people should or shouldn't enjoy music?
But,
um,
I think a lot of the Beatles backlash just has to do with everybody blowing them
for the last fucking 50 years.
And people will be like,
dude,
yellow submarine.
That's a good song.
And it's like,
well dude,
Al Pachino has bad movies.
Does that mean he's not a fucking,
one of the greatest actors of all time?
You know,
every comedian has a fucking tough set.
Everybody comedian tells a joke that doesn't fucking work.
Richard Pryor did sets where he bond.
You know,
I,
I don't understand the,
whatever.
It was such a stupid fucking thing I got.
I just literally wasted,
I wasted like two hours of my life arguing about whether the Beatles were great
or not.
And whether or not what Duran was doing was,
you know,
a legit championship or not.
I wasted like at least two hours of my fucking life debating with that,
getting nowhere spinning my wheels.
The other person argue with any just fucking went nowhere.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I got another birthday coming up and I really thought I was past this point in
my life.
I don't know why.
Fair enough.
Just didn't pop into my head.
Oh,
I know why.
Because I was drinking as always when I'm on the fucking road.
And uh,
I decided,
uh,
this morning when I woke up and I was like,
did I really stay out until four in the morning?
You know,
trying to just tell somebody why the Beatles are better than a waste cysts in
the foo fighters did.
I really just try to do that,
that I really sit there and debate fucking the Kevin Durant's rate sometimes at
the top of my lungs until four in the fucking morning.
So now I got to do press it to listen to this shit.
I'm not going to work out this morning.
I could've gone down the street.
I should've gone to fucking bed.
Go back to the room.
That's what I should've done.
I could have gone to bed.
I could have woke up,
gone to the gym.
I could've played drums this morning and I'm not.
It's fucking 12 noon.
Try to get my shit together.
And you know what?
I've added.
I've had it.
I'm fucking shutting it down.
Shutting it down.
Yeah,
I,
you know what?
No,
I'm no fun,
William.
That's all I'm going to be no fun.
Billy.
No Fun.
There you go.
There's my new name.
Billy.
No Fun.
Oh,
Billy.
Back to the room.
I just,
I don't know what a fucking colossal fucking waste.
That's all I can think about this morning.
You guys have to do that.
You had to have,
am I the only person who does shit like that goes out and stays out way past the
time.
He should have stayed out debating stupid shit.
Why do I give a fuck if someone likes the red hot chili peppers over fucking,
I dunno.
Fucking poison.
Why?
And I'm 49 years old on Saturday.
I'm having arguments that I should've been having in like fucking junior high
and high school.
I Dunno.
I want to say I took a long,
hard look at myself,
but I didn't,
I kind of laid here with the fucking lights off,
just going like I can't,
yeah.
Uh,
I dunno.
Then I'm trying to like make excuses.
Well,
I'm just upset because I'm not going to see my daughter for the next couple of
days,
so maybe that caused me to be a little more argumentative and then I had to
really look at myself and be like,
you know what belt now you kind of been a client for a while now
this predates the birth of your daughter.
Um,
so anyways,
no fun Billy.
Oh,
back to the room,
Roger.
That's what I'm going to be.
MMM.
Yeah.
Tonight I think I'm going to have dinner with an old friend.
Right.
Which sounds like code that I'm going to go out and go do some heroin,
you know?
Isn't that code in the junky world?
Where were you for the last six weeks?
I was having dinner with an old friend,
you know,
we eat standing up,
um,
sorry,
sorry for the heroin jokes considering it's a goddamn epidemic here in the
United States.
Um,
but what kind of a jazz are actually a functioning junking listening to this
shit right now.
Um,
do you think you could kick her?
Would you ever see people kicking heroin and you think like what?
I have it in me.
I mean,
I can't even lay up the booze.
I saw this video one time,
this guy just like literally on his knees folded down on top of himself in the
tub,
just feels like with water running over him.
And this woman was sort of giving them shit.
Give me like,
oh,
how do you feel?
Just sort of looks up like,
I can't imagine it,
but,
um,
I've read a couple of rockstars books and they talk about,
you know,
trying to kick heroin and all that stuff and it's,
I dunno why it sounds like fascinating.
Whenever I,
uh,
whenever around in your arms again,
dude,
that songs better than the Beatles.
I like,
I liked that song.
Makes me want to get up and go on a power walk.
Uh,
no.
Um,
love you much better.
[inaudible] head.
Sorry.
Um,
um,
what was I talking about?
Kicking heroin.
Who the fuck was that?
That I just think
that's not Spandau Ballet.
Yeah.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
I know this,
that was spanned.
All right.
One,
two.
Who,
that was a tough summer when that song came out,
you know what I mean?
You'd have a crush on a girl and she pulled up in a car and as much as you loved
her,
you just couldn't quite love her as much when she pulled up any,
she was listening to that song.
Uh Huh.
You know,
it's kind of impossible if you love music to start to start to sing that song
without beginning to cry.
It's such a bad song.
Right.
Oh,
oh,
I know
this.
Sorry.
Um,
anyways,
I want to thank everybody once again,
as I just mentioned that uh,
helped me come in.
I,
I can't even say I wasn't there from like eight 45 in the morning until four in
the afternoon,
just running my,
Yap.
About this show and,
uh,
I got to do it again this afternoon.
Then I have a little more in the morning and then I am done and I have like one
more pressing than I think I'm doing.
And then that's it.
That's it.
Then I washed my hands of it.
And if you fucking like it,
you watch it.
If you don't,
you don't.
I apologize for the click here and you go,
it's probably was overly loud.
Um,
I get to look at my fucking notes here.
I think Debbie,
buddy,
uh,
I guess I did.
I talked about the guy with the elliptical.
Yes,
I did.
Um,
I'm actually been paying attention a little bit to the Red Sox,
Yankees,
the red sox to new evil empire,
$210 million coming down and playing these upstart Yankees,
you know,
all from the farm system,
the Anti Golden State Warriors.
You know what I mean?
You know what the Yankees,
the Yankees in like 99,
2000 till,
I don't know,
2009,
2010,
right to the end of George Steinberg,
his life.
That was like when Hulk Hogan has,
you know,
he still has the blonde mustache,
but his beard is black,
you know,
he's the bad guy.
And right now what the Yankees are doing,
they're like Hulk Hogan when he has just the blonde mustache and he's a good guy
and he's wearing the red with the orange writing on his fucking ass shorts.
He's not wearing the black shit,
letting you know that for some reason he's in an evil place.
And the,
the red sox right now,
the red sox got the black beard.
We are the black bearded fucking blood mustache version of how Cogan coming to
town,
throwing a fucking money all over the place,
you know.
Um,
I dunno.
Well,
so we'll see.
But we gotta fucking asses kicked last night.
I think we won the night before.
I'm starting to pay attention.
I'm going to get the fucking MLB package.
I'm going to see what $210 million does.
Um,
you know,
I actually think it's,
it's probably going to be bad.
I'm going to sit there and thinking about having my daughter on my lap watching
those games.
I think there's not enough movement for a toddler to issued toddler,
I guess a baby to appreciate that.
So what's great about hockey,
by the way,
how about those predators coming back and tying up the series?
How about that?
You know,
I'd be very excited if I was a Predator is fan,
but I would still be nervous obviously playing the penguins.
And I'll tell you why was because of the way Crosby's celebrated that breakaway
goal the other night.
I loved that he just went in a fucking scores the goal and rather than flipping
out,
he just,
he puts his arms out to the side to bring in the teammates.
Like all right,
there's one like total fucking business look on his face.
You know,
every time the Predator score they're doing like the fucking mock arena.
You know what I mean?
They're doing the electric slide,
they've fist pump and they're going crazy.
They are Christ.
There are a bunch of Goddamn kids acting like they never been there before.
And you know what?
They haven't,
and I'm not saying that they're going to lose this series,
but I w I would be very concerned if I was to coach or the predators looking at
how,
you know,
cause we just had that fucking assess and look in his face.
So what do you think?
Was it game five if you like competition?
I would watch the Stanley Cup final rather than finals or vinyl versus the NBA
finals.
I always forget which one's plural and somebody last year fucking goes,
there's only one final.
There's not too.
And it's like,
all right,
well they call it the end.
They call it the NBA finals.
I believe one of them,
one of them is fucking plural.
Um,
but the cab game night was fucking great.
I was going nuts cheering right until the goddamn end,
until Duran,
that beast,
you know,
we get that fucking three,
but he really is a fucking monster.
Just a phenomenal player.
Oh my God.
Would it be great if he was still on the thunder?
Can you imagine the series,
the rematch they would have had,
you know,
they should do that with like a superhero movie.
It just have like superman join Lex Luther
and then they just fly around and run around.
Just beating the shit out of people.
Can Lex was Lex Luthor tough?
What exactly was that guy?
He really had no super powers.
He just was a really negative dude.
Right.
And you comic con people.
Can you help me out on that one?
You somehow,
I don't know.
What is the,
he was just sort of an asshole who had hookups to,
uh,
that green shit.
Superman doesn't like the fuck.
Is that algae?
Is it a Kale?
What is it that he kryptonite the Kryptonite.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't get that like it comes from the planet.
Krypton right.
Isn't that as natural environment?
I actually think that that's lazy writing.
You know,
it comes to the planet Krypton and his one weakness is crip night.
Yeah.
I'm from Earth.
I have super powers in boat.
Just don't get me anywhere near Earth.
Earth.
Oh,
night.
that's it.
Oh my freckles fall off.
I can't tell jokes anymore.
Maybe that's why this podcast sucks so bad right now.
Not because I'm fucking hating what I've done over the last fucking 12 hours to
myself.
Maybe it has to do with the fact that uh,
there's some earth at night here in my,
in my apartment.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
after I do the press today and after I do the press to Myra,
um,
I'm going up to Montreal doing two shows on my birthday,
you know,
this is the loneliness of the road.
I just have to like,
um,
you gotta steer into it sometimes and just see the humor in it.
I wanted to the drug store right.
And I was walking through the aisles,
they're trying to find some Burt's bees wax for my fucking dried out lips,
you know,
cause I haven't been drinking enough water or whatever the fuck being a goddamn
idiot out here.
And um,
I walked by this aisle and I saw that they had those numbers.
You know that you put on a birthday cake.
That's sorry I bought a foreign and nine and I'm going to buy myself on Friday
cause I'm not going to have time.
I don't think on my birthday and I'm going to fucking buy myself light those.
And I'm going to take a Selfie of me with a sad look on my face with a little
piece of cheesecake.
Happy Birthday to me,
Abby birthday to me poo.
Who?
Um,
anyways,
I don't,
Oh shit.
I don't know how far into this fucking podcast I am.
This always happens when I go to do this.
All right,
let me,
uh,
let me read the advertising.
Okay.
And I've been getting a ton of shit.
Evidently I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking hard on these,
these advertisers.
So you know,
in the,
in the spirit of the fact that my daughter is going to go to that,
my daughter in there,
I like dod is going to go to fucking,
um,
college one day,
God knows what the fuck that's going to forget college,
right?
Forget Paris.
They fucking,
what are you going to do now?
Now you gotta you gotta pay the Vig to secondary and the like kindergarten
you've got his pay.
Like,
you know,
La schools are so bad if you don't get them in print.
And you've got to get him in private school in the very beginning.
You've got to start paying into the system and that gives you a better fucking
chance.
Just a better chance of them getting into,
I don't,
elementary school or middle school is such,
such a rip off.
I don't know what's happening in public schools.
Is it because of the overhead is like so much worse.
I was talking about this on somebody's,
Oh Pete Dominick show.
Thank you to him for let me in on a show.
Um,
yeah,
Pete Dominick show the,
uh,
we were talking about that like when I was a kid,
way back fucking went,
you know,
when you went to public school,
like they just had these fucking textbooks that they just kept giving people
year after year after year.
Like,
I remember the late seventies and just seeing like,
like 78 you know,
and you'd see this holistic kids who had it and they would just have like,
you know,
77 78 would be me than somebody.
The year before was 76 77 and it would go all the way back to like the early
sixties or mid sixties so they buy textbooks like once every 15 years.
You know,
your mother went out and bought me a new pair of sneakers and a couple pairs of
Toughskins right.
You had hand me down shirts from the older brother and all you do show up with
the fucking pencil and you are ready to,
and I don't know.
They had,
they had paper,
that's what they need.
They need the need paper or whatever.
And these just,
you know,
hand out these fucking old textbooks.
That was it.
That's all they had to do.
And I'm now the kids,
what do they got?
They gotta have,
they gotta have the phones.
They got to have the fucking iPads,
computers and all this shit.
MMM.
Maybe that's what it is.
The overhead for each fucking kid is like,
like the amount of money that they spend on like one kid who is probably what
they spent on like a hundred
well build.
Did you do any research to see if that math worked out?
Of course.
Now the fuck podcasts you'd think you listened to this on this podcast is not
about actual information.
All right.
Uh,
Luke crate everybody.
Give me the loop.
Be The envy of your friends and get your 100% exclusive
crates@lootcrate.com slash burr.
Enter my code burr to save $3 off any new subscription.
Isn't that a movie?
Some paper boys screaming $3.
It's the one where the guy who held the boom box over his head.
Don't you forget about me?
Uh,
June's loot crate theme.
His alter ego alter ego or as I called the my drunk self.
What do you mean the Beatles?
Irrelevant rated.
Can I get the Hash browns?
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical fashion needs to then try loop where this isn't
woo where it says nothing to do with the Wu Tang.
This is Luke where monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your
favorite franchises.
If you want to get fancy man,
get a bigger box with even bigger Lou with loot crate DX.
Want to geek out with your pet.
Ah,
try loop pets offer expires June 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific and you geek out with
your pet.
I didn't know the dogs have that ability.
They freak out.
Uh,
in June you run around in a circle with your pet peed on the floor and Jews loot
crate,
you'll find items from Spiderman.
My favorite transform is the hulk.
Another one I like that I relayed to,
you know,
I can be a big green drunk myself.
That DC comics,
one lucky subscriber will also win a mega crate,
mega crate.
Not Mega Church.
No.
Joel Olsteen here.
This is mega crate of seriously epic proportional proportions.
Uh,
you have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe and receive that month's
crate.
And when the cut off happens.
That's it.
It's over.
Uh,
go to Luke,
Luke craig.com/burn.
Enter my code burr and say $3 off on any new subscription today.
All right.
What'd you guys think of that?
Read?
I thought that that was pretty nice,
but I,
you know,
I think I can be even more pleasant
lift when you drive the right ride sharing app.
Every trip can feel like a walk in the park with Lyft.
I can't do this shit with Lyft.
You can pick your own hours and work when you want.
Live can make driving the best job in the world.
Lift.
You know,
I wish they had this one.
I was a kid because I would have done this and I had an 83 Ford ranger and I
would either have some Weirdo sitting next to me or I would just throw him in
the back of the truck.
Sorry ladies.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating it's people better.
Lift believes that being a ride sharing drivers should be fun if you're having a
good time.
So are the passengers.
Um,
if you choose,
if you're choosing a ride sharing company to drive for,
go with the company that treats you better.
Lift,
lift offers in APP tipping.
Okay,
but you drive for Lyft.
You could keep one unappreciative of the tips.
Drivers have been paid over $150 million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Isn't that amazing that that level of cash even exists out there?
Express?
Well,
I guess there's over 300 million people out there,
bill and every other person had a dollar.
You'd have a 150 million express pay lets drivers get paid,
paid almost instantly instead of waiting for weeks.
A Lyft has taken the guesswork out of pickups.
The new APP devices uses color coding to help passengers find their drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips,
want to make more money,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a raise.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers being unhappy passengers,
man.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 lift drivers get a perfect five star rating.
I wonder what happened to the other guy so that joy.
So join the ride sharing company that believes in treating its people better.
Go to lift.com/bird today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's
lyft.com/bar
lyft.com/bar high
lift.com/barb limited time only to terms apply.
I've always wanted to say that it's not our fault if we kill your kid.
All right,
me on bs a Dodo,
the me on days,
me ids don't be a dick.
When you read the do to do the advertising,
you have a ties in.
We'll take the money away and then you'll bleed.
Um,
right in your fucking soft underwear.
Your balls are bleeding and you should care.
Nobody wants bloody nuts and you'll never have those with fucking and fucking me
on these.
Um,
elevate your underwear game to the next level with me on ds.
You perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs.
I have something that will change your life for the better.
It's me on these once the first thing you put on and the last thing you'd take
off,
Cologne glitter or you a stripper.
Do you go to strip clubs?
If you're a regular person,
it's underwear.
Um,
make your most important piece of clothing the best they can be with me on
these.
Mandy's softer than soft luxury on these come in an ever changing selection of
classic colors.
Bold shapes,
bold shapes.
I mean what,
how many different sizes?
Like acids and hips can you,
I guess they have patterns.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't design underwear and adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to make your own personal style.
They mean like banana hammock versus boxer style.
That's what they mean by shapes.
You know,
who would've thought you could dress your dick up in so many different ways?
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly and if you're not ready
for a subscription,
that's okay.
You can still say that's because [inaudible] is offering you 20% off your first
pair.
Just use our special URL me,
undies.com/burn and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
Once again,
the me on.com/ [inaudible] that's me.
[inaudible] dot com slash burn me on these.com/burr Oh my God.
This is like affecting my mood.
I'm reading these so pleasantly.
M V m t movement movement,
watches per unannounced movement was founded on the belief that style shouldn't
break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way you consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at a revolutionary price with over a
hundred million watches sold to customers in 160 plus countries around the world
world world world movement watches has solidified itself as the world's fastest
growing watch company.
We weren't you storage's $35 man at a department store.
You're looking at four to five on a bucks.
You know why?
Cause they have to pay rent at the department store.
Not these guys.
These guys are in a one bedroom apartment.
They're like a bunch of hoarders sitting there with all their watches waiting
for you to spend 95 bucks so they can breathe again and maybe get into some sort
of functional fucking relationship movement figured out that by selling online
they were able to cut out the middleman.
That's the department store and retail markup providing the best possible price.
Classic design,
quality construction,
and styled the minimal of them.
Over 1 million watches sold in over 160 countries.
I wonder if any dictators have on a movement watch.
You know what I mean?
Get 50% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/burr.
I mean 160 countries are there 160 democracies out there?
What has happened to democracy?
I don't know.
The watch has a really clean design.
Seriously.
Um,
you'll be getting compliments every l the second you put the fucking thing on.
Movement watches,
things grow.
It makes a great gift.
Whether you're celebrating a grand,
a graduation,
sorry,
or your dad father's day.
Hinton father's Day movement is the perfect place to shop.
Father's Day.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] father's day.
Join the movement.
Get the old man or watch,
uh,
policy genius.
This is the last one.
All right?
You've asked it if you don't have life insurance,
what would happen financially if something happened to the primary earner?
Dude,
I have to tell you,
if you've got a family,
you've got a few to get a family baggage.
You got to fucking do it,
okay?
You have to do it.
Um,
I didn't want to do this for the longest time because it reminded me that I was
going to die,
but I got to tell you something.
Now that I have it,
now that I have life insurance,
I swear to God,
you know,
I'm going to get a motorcycle without a helmet.
When you're popping wheelies,
driving down the street,
just screaming at my wife,
it's okay.
I have life insurance.
You're going to be fine.
That's,
you know something.
You don't want your last dying words on the side of the road to look in your
wife's eyes and say,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
this street,
I'm dying and you're now going to be living it.
Don't you want to look at it and be like,
it's going to be fine.
You're going to be all set.
You know before you slip off into the abyss.
I'm trying to say you got to get life insurance,
but I want an easy way to do it.
Policy genius.
Life insurance is a good idea to protect the ones around you,
but where do you go to get the best prices and the best policy with the best
service policy?
genius.com if all you dopes out their genius is spelled g,
e n,
I,
U s not j e a n u s
policy.com is a the best online life insurance marketplace.
The most accurate quotes from the top a rated life insurance company's policy
genius has placed over $5 billion in life insurance for people like you.
Policy Genius has a very simple user friendly website to shop and compare all
the top rated life insurance companies and give you the best options and they
have a light and they have a licensed customer service team to help you find the
best policy at the best price.
While you're there,
check out their other insurance offerings like pet insurance.
Yeah,
you don't want your pet to die in the road and be looking up at you like you
know this is gonna really be lonely.
You know when your pet dies,
you want to know that you can run right out with tears in your eyes and get
another one immediately,
immediately to place your other dog.
Go to policy genius.com to save over 40% you know like second,
you break up with someone,
you run out and you get into another relationship.
40% off prices for life insurance.
When life insurance companies compete for your business,
you save money.
That's policy genius.
P,
O,
l I C Y G E N A U S.
Dot Com
zero jargon.
Zero sales pressure,
zero hassles,
man.
Life insurance made easy.
Free quotes,
zero hassle,
peace of mind.
Don't wait.
Go to policy,
genius.com today.
Um,
all right.
I think that's the podcast for today.
Oh,
who's coming down the street?
Who's got freckled feet?
It's Billy and he's having no fun.
That's who I'm going to be over the next fucking,
I dunno how long.
Oh Billy,
no fun.
What can I do to improve my life?
I know have less fun.
That's how it works.
That's what aging is.
You know what my problem is?
Lately I've been having too much fun.
But the problem is,
is once you're a fucking adult,
you know,
and you,
once you move out,
your parents aren't,
your mothers are not there anymore to tell you to,
you know the fucking knock it off.
You have to have your own.
You gotta be your own fucking parent.
I think I used to do a bit on this.
Am I becoming a parody of myself?
Do you guys believe in that?
Can you be a parody yourself?
Or is it does,
what it really means is you figured people and figured you out and they're used
to what you do.
MMM.
How can you be impersonating yourself?
Didn't that guy from fucking Creedence Clearwater revival.
Then you get sued for sounding like Cleveland Credence.
John Fogarty is former managers sued him for sounding too much like Creedence
Clearwater revival and he actually,
he actually,
he actually had to go to fucking trial many times that I just say actually new
drinking game every time bill says,
actually you have to do a shot laughing my ass off while shaking my head.
Um,
yeah.
John Fogarty actually got fucking sued for sounding like too much like credence
clear one over providable.
Um,
I think that he had a first ballot hall of fame.
Okay.
Fucking piece of shit manager.
You know what I mean?
He had one of the worst managers of all God damn time is what I'm trying to say.
Um,
I'm turning this day around people.
This is the new silver me.
Who is that?
Walking down the street?
That's a new,
my new theme sung.
Who's the guy with the freckled fee?
It's Billy and he's having no fun.
I'm going to sing that to my wife.
That's how I'm going to wake her up.
Um,
she likes to silly song.
Do you like a silly song?
Do you like the songs that make the whole world sing?
I have a new song for you
now.
You maybe heard of this band.
Okay.
Now I'm not saying there was good as a waste.
This,
I'm not saying there is good as Nickelback.
All right.
I don't want to start a fucking debate here
but um,
mute.
Matt has a new fucking single lap.
I believe it's called hit parade and a,
I think that's what you're going to be listening to.
Next mute.
Matt is who you met this,
this is amazing band that uh,
the Monday morning podcast on Andrew Stimulus.
Um,
he was the first guy that told me about them and I've seen them in concert two
or three times.
They're absolutely fucking amazing.
I mean,
I don't know if this is going to make you want to get on an elliptical.
I dunno if this band passes the leg warmer test that my buddies,
you know,
use when they listen to the bands.
Um,
I,
but I do think that this will actually make you want to at least,
I dunno,
maybe touch your toes a couple of times.
I have no idea.
Please enjoy new math.
Please enjoy your weekend.
You conch.
I'm going to Montreal,
one of my favorite cities and on Sunday I'm going to the Formula One race and
I'm going to watch the Ferrari's in the Mercedes.
Is,
is,
is in all those fucking guys driving around the track.
It's going to be fucking amazing.
I cannot believe that I'm going to that.
And yeah,
that's it.
I'm continuing with my privileged white male life.
You know,
it's unbelievable.
And I only wish people who weren't white male heterosexuals could understand.
Just like,
do you have any fucking idea what it's like to be me right now?
I'm going to open my door.
Okay.
And this is going to be a little gold coin and a USA Today given to me by the
government.
I shouldn't tell you this,
but that's what,
that's how white I am.
Yeah.
The government.
Thanks me every day for it.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
I just tried to touch my screen.
Like,
this is my iPhone.
I love Billy.
No Fun.
Has to kick into overdrive.
You all right?
Enjoy the music.
He is a final Straw.
[inaudible]
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
happy birthday to me.
Birthday
me
happy birthday to
me.
See
what's going on.
Is built bird some Monday morning podcast that I'm actually doing on Wednesday,
June 10th,
2009,
uh,
my 41st birthday.
And uh,
I'm on the road and I'm going to be on the road here for Awhile and,
uh,
I'm on the road for a month and I didn't bring my microphone.
I didn't bring my,
I didn't bring any of that shit.
So the next four podcasts,
they're going to sound like this,
which isn't too bad,
but it isn't too great either.
But,
um,
yeah,
it's my fucking birthday and I'm a New York City and I'm all by myself and,
uh,
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
I'm going to go eat some oatmeal and take a walk in the park.
Huh?
Like a fucking old bastard.
Jesus Christ 41.
What happened?
Um,
anyways,
for those of you new to my page,
this is the Monday morning podcasts that I usually do on Monday,
and then I can't figure out how to fucking upload it.
So usually it doesn't come out till Tuesday or sometimes until Wednesday.
And uh,
for my 14,
actually 13,
after that fucking chick flipped out on me last week,
my 13 listeners fucked at,
there's got to be still 14.
Somebody came on this week.
I like saint 14.
So for my 14 listeners out there,
um,
the reason why it's taken me till Wednesday to put this thing up is because I'm
on Monday.
Some of you might've seen,
I did the tonight show with Conan O'brien and I had the unbelievable honor of
being the first comedian to be on the tonight show under the Conan O'brien
regime.
Um,
it went awesome.
I kind of felt like I was eating my balls up front.
But,
uh,
you know,
when your first joke,
the first punchline is that's what you get.
You dumb bitch.
I don't know how many laps you can expect.
If I could have done the set over,
I probably would have probably opened with the thing about the girl at the
restaurant commenting on how many Asians were in the restaurant.
But then that would have been weird because,
uh,
what would the first laugh be?
This is gonna seem oddly racist.
And then I was like,
well,
this is gonna be awesome.
And if I,
that was my first joke,
then they'd be like,
wow,
is this guy like openly racist?
Is this what the tonight show under the Conan O'brien regime is going to be
like?
But,
uh,
no,
it was,
it ended up going great.
Um,
I finally got them on board right after I was trashing children and I started
talking about microchipping people and then they got on board and it went great
right after that.
And,
uh,
the setups incredible.
And,
uh,
it was,
it was awesome.
Man.
I'm looking forward to hopefully doing 9,000 more because it was a,
I dunno,
it was quite a rush.
And for those of you who aren't comedians and you want to know what it's like to
do something that,
um,
those sets are actually for me anyways,
I find those that there are a lot harder than,
um,
than actually doing half hour or hour specials because,
it's only four and a half minutes.
You can't curse and it's so easy to bomb.
It's,
it's literally the standup version.
You just walking out there with a gun to your head for basically four and a half
minutes.
Go and have my funny,
ah,
my still funny about now.
Did you like that one?
Oh,
thank God.
Good night.
That's basically the way it is.
And this is the first time.
Um,
I've had to work out a four and a half minutes set in Los Angeles,
which is a difficult thing to do and I want to thank the,
uh,
the Improv and the comedy store for,
letting me run the set a bunch of times.
But,
uh,
it was la crowds are not New York crowds.
I don't want to start a little fucking biggie Tupac thing going on here.
But,
uh,
one of the last times I did my fucking set,
I went on in front of like eight people and I'm literally waiting to go on.
And this girl comes in bleach blonde hair,
she's talking on her cell phone,
walking right up to the second row is some poor bastards on stage.
Just eaten his balls or doing whatever you're doing in front of eight people.
Right?
And you know,
she's one of the eight and she's walking in on her phone completely oblivious,
not talking loud,
but you know,
and I was just laughing at myself going like that as a classic La moment right
there.
So then I went up to run my set and I'm thinking,
uh,
you know,
this was literally the night before I was going to do it.
And I was like,
alright,
don't like the fact that there's only eight people in the crowd.
Fuck with you.
You know,
just do your thing.
Just commit to everything.
This is no joke,
you know,
before we're doing it tomorrow night.
And I went up and I proceeded to ever so slowly just munch my balls for fucking
five minutes or whatever and uh,
to the end to to the point where I got to the final joke and I didn't even say
it,
I just said,
you know what?
You people suck.
And then I started ripping on the girl with the blonde hair and the cell phone
and she's like,
Oh my God,
I'm sorry.
And I'm like,
no,
you're not.
You're just embarrassed.
Okay.
I hate when people do that.
You know,
you call them out on their stuff.
Oh God,
I didn't realize.
How do you not know how fucking rude that is?
I think I said to wear it to the CRA,
the can't even say the crowd to the group,
to the family of seven,
the other seven fucking people.
I was like,
can you imagine being that good looking where you're not even aware that that's
rude to do something like that?
I'm,
I'm talking like walking right up to the stage on your cell phone.
She didn't seem to be talking to,
maybe she was just listening to messages.
Maybe I was just freaking out because,
uh,
every other time I did my set,
I was fucking bombing.
So anyways,
so I ended my set on the tonight show and I felt like I bombed.
I'm just cause up front,
you know,
they were a little quiet and um,
but I knew I pulled it out,
but everybody was nice at the show and everybody was thrilled.
So I was thrilled.
And um,
had a real embarrassing moment after I got off stage was,
it's weird when you do those things [inaudible] they just go by so fucking fast.
And I literally,
you know,
they wrapped up the end of the show.
And as always,
whenever I stand next to Conan,
I look like I'm five foot two and that half the emails I get are great set.
Wow.
Conan is really tall and yes,
he is really tall and no,
I am not five foot five.
I'm about five foot 10 just under.
And uh,
I don't know what the fuck he is,
but um,
he was a tall individual.
So anyways,
so I walk off stage in all my,
you know,
manager,
agent and
all these people in my girlfriend was staying there and I'm so like fucking
like,
was it good?
Was it good?
Everyone's going,
good job,
good job.
And I shook everybody's hand and my girlfriend literally goes,
great job honey.
And I shook her hand like she was a fucking a PA
and she literally goes,
just shaking my hand.
What the fuck?
And then everyone started laughing at me and I was really,
really embarrassed.
I felt like an idiot.
And I tried to explain how I was.
I was in my head and,
uh,
I don't know.
Then I realized that did go awesome and everyone was smiling and,
and I knew it went great.
I could just tell just the way white people,
people,
you know,
when it doesn't go great that there's not a bunch of people standing there
backstage.
And when,
you know,
there are people,
they tend to be looking down at the floor or acting as though they have to get
out of there.
No,
no,
no.
It was good.
And then they fucking beat it.
And then you want to fucking jump off a building.
So fortunately that didn't happen and I got a ton of great emails of people
complimented me on my set and I want to thank everybody who sent those in
because uh,
you know,
that was a,
that was a really,
you know,
first guy to be on the Conan O'brien tonight show.
I got to tell you guys that's his big as anything I've done.
So,
uh,
I'm flying pretty high right now and a,
and I want to thank all you guys for all the really supportive great emails that
you guys sent me.
It really,
you know,
I was definitely,
uh,
one of those points in your career where you sit back for a second,
make sure you take it in.
So I want to thank everybody and uh,
I'd read all the good emails,
but uh,
those ones are never funny,
but you know what are funny are the ones when I get trashed.
So why don't I read one of those?
Okay.
Um,
this is an email,
um,
that is about my tonight show set and it is titled in all capitals.
No more shiny suits.
All right,
here we go.
So strap in for this one.
Bill,
I was so happy to see you on Kona tonight.
I am a huge fan for years and I was so excited to see you perform.
But what the fuck are you thinking with the shiny suits?
This shiny gray suit with the shiny purple shirt was positively all capitals
distracting.
Whoever is in charge of your wardrobe needs to be cut.
If it is your girlfriend.
She needs to understand the east coast,
west coast different difference.
La is pretty much a bunch of,
I don't know what this word is.
P R o g.
E n Y.
Prague.
Annie.
She tried to say phony anyways is a bunch of uh,
somethings of Hollywood or Stanford or modeling companies.
You are the Boston blue collar hockey loving reality spewing comedian,
comedian.
You are the dude who only wears a suit to funerals and maybe weddings.
Am I,
I didn't know that.
If it was Conan show,
who made you aware that they are idiots?
Oh,
have you know sweetheart,
I love suits and I love wearing them.
I love that.
I'm the blue code blue collar.
I can fucking barely hammer a nail.
What?
Cause I say fuck a lot.
I love all people just,
they just think like you're this one dimensional individual.
I do love hockey,
but that doesn't mean I can't wear a suit.
I don't even know it.
Are you doing like a caricature of of of a person really?
He says fuck a lot.
That means he only weighs two.
All right,
let's just read the rest of this.
All right.
If it was Conan show,
right?
Okay.
The battery joke was great,
but otherwise I could not stop thinking.
Why is he wearing that shiny suit?
What's going on?
Was that really what you were thinking?
You were watching me.
I could see you going.
Why is he wearing that shiny suit?
But did you literally think what's going on?
Did you think something happened like they fucking,
they stuck a microchip in the back of my head.
What's going on?
What have they done to him anyways?
You dated yourself so much,
especially since you are growing your hair again,
which I think is a great idea,
sweetheart.
I'm actually growing up because I am doing a small part in a movie and they
asked me to grow it back out and the second it's over,
I'm shaving it again.
All right,
so,
uh,
when I'm glad you think it's a great idea.
Anyways,
wearing a suit,
you did not look like yourself at all.
Capital Letters.
I have been a fan since I saw you on the Cam Neely special over 15 years ago and
you have always been that guy who says what everyone thinks,
but please do not ever wear that suit on stage again.
Jesus Christ was it that bad?
Anyways,
your comedy is very street quotes,
every man quotes and socially and racially inclusive.
But to see you wearing an awful shiny early nineties outfit was almost
heartbreaking.
But even even worse,
it was all capitals distracting.
I just kept thinking,
good God,
he is a cute guy.
What the Hell is he wearing?
You thought all this and four and a half fucking minutes if keeps going.
There we go.
It is part of your routine to be the regular guy in quotes.
Quotes again.
Regular guys do not wear suits on Monday night.
Yeah.
Get on your jeans and casual,
buttoned down shirt and your audience will laugh again.
What did you have a feed to?
Everyone who enjoys my comedy anyways.
Uh,
she said I'm in New York City.
The opinion that La tried to start trends.
What the opinion that La tried to start trends but only New York City can do.
It is true.
Bring back the real bill burr.
I love the real bill.
How fucked up is that?
I just emailed her back and I just wrote,
you are out of your mind.
Um,
God,
there was so much fucking hilarious shit.
I love that she felt it was so distracting.
I thought what it was over.
Please do not ever wear a suit on stage again.
You would think that at that point,
you know,
27 paragraphs,
she had made her point and she goes back into it again saying,
I'm very street.
Very every man sweetheart,
you don't know anything about me.
I grew up in the suburbs.
It was very safe.
My parents are professionals.
Uh,
we just happen to grow up in a blue collar town.
I lived on the east coast,
so all of us sound like we understand plumbing.
I,
I do have a little toolbox.
Um,
my knowledge of car engines are as a changing the oil in the air filter.
I tried to change a fuel filter.
I did that a couple times successfully and one time I actually at least snapped
it off and I had to have my truck towed down to,
uh,
to the fucking garage.
And I told the guy I snapped it off and I left the fuel filter on the seat.
Evidently he didn't listen to me and one of his guys got in the car,
started the truck up,
gas when all over the engine and my truck burned to the ground.
And then the guy tried to call me up in guerrilla his way through it.
You know,
going,
what the fuck you told me you twisted it.
We just had a fire.
That's what he kept saying.
And I was like,
no,
dude,
you just had a fire.
Okay.
I told you,
I twist.
You said you snack.
Yeah.
You said you twisted.
I said,
no.
I snapped it off I go,
I left the fucking fuel filter right on the Goddamn seat.
He goes,
you know what?
I'm so fucking sick.
You guys,
you know,
you start the jobs and you fuck it up and then you bring it down to me.
Yeah,
my truck is broken.
Fix it.
You fucking cunt.
You're a mechanic.
What did other people bring cars in that a totally fixed.
Ah,
that's a whole nother fucking story.
Um,
and now you're probably saying,
well,
look it,
look it.
You drove a truck.
That means you're blue collar.
Now.
It doesn't,
it does,
it.
I just,
you know,
it was a car.
There was a truck and I,
I,
you know,
I could afford it and I was 17,
so I bought it.
And I also had this idea that I was going to deliver papers in the morning and
make some more money,
you know?
And then I'd also have my afternoon job cause that's what I was into.
And uh,
when I told people at school that that's what I was going to do,
they were all like two,
four,
you're going to be a paper boy.
What are you a fag?
And then I immediately ditch that idea cause I had no confidence in myself.
And,
uh,
then I had some stupid truck that I didn't use.
But that's a whole nother story.
Um,
and getting back to me,
uh,
in the suit,
um,
shiny suit,
uh,
in real life.
It's not shiny.
I can't help HD television.
Hd Television makes everything look way more fucking vivid,
you know,
like colors.
I mean,
come on.
You know,
when you go to a baseball game,
can you see the pores of the players?
I mean it's fucking,
it's too weird,
man.
I'm actually not a fan of HDTV.
I wish they had the big screen TVs and they just went back to regular TV.
Cause uh,
I'm not really a fan of that.
And as far as your New York City,
Los Angeles,
your big finger on the pulse of fashion.
That was actually,
I bought it at Barney's in New York,
in La.
I get,
what do they not have?
The suits that they in New York.
And it was also,
I believe it was a Gucci suit,
which is made in Italy.
So that has nothing to do with Los Angeles and a,
I'm not street and I'm not every man.
Okay.
You know,
you sound like a casting director.
Yeah.
So I just wrote back to her,
uh,
you are out of your mind because I wasn't really gonna waste the fucking time of
,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
Trying to fucking explain all that,
but you know,
that's what happens.
People,
that's what happens when you,
uh,
that's the internet.
You know,
what the fuck was,
I don't give a shit.
You could fucking literally,
I dunno,
Cura disease and that would still be somebody going,
what the fuck were you thinking?
You know,
Karen Cancer,
do you realize what that's gonna do?
The World Joe already overpopulated and what the fuck was with those shiny
scrubs?
Um,
anyways,
who gives a fuck?
Who gives a fuck?
I got to do the tonight show.
Actually,
I actually,
when that email came out,
I got it,
uh,
probably about maybe three hours after I did the tonight show.
And it's really funny living on the West Coast because I'm obviously,
I'm used to living on the east coast and when you're on the east coast,
you take the show,
um,
just before 6:00 PM is when you go on,
they take from five to six,
so you've got five hours before anybody sees it.
But um,
you know,
and then people out in La,
it's eight hours and then you tape it out in La.
It's like you'd do it and literally three hours later people that are out
sending you emails about it.
So I had just,
you know,
I went out and I had a steak dinner and all that stuff.
Had a great fucking time,
felt like 1 million bucks.
And I was sitting there and uh,
when I got the email,
um,
I actually,
I read it to my girlfriend and we got a,
we both had a really big laugh when we were reading it,
just,
just how long it was and uh,
and our description of me,
um,
I dunno,
Jesus Christ,
let me talking about this as almost as long as the fucking email.
Um,
yeah.
So they go with that email.
You actually learned some shit about me.
I happen to love suits.
I love it wearing them and um,
but not shitty suits,
you know,
I really don't like wearing shitty suits.
And to be honest with you,
anytime I do a late night talk show,
I always go out and I buy a brand new suit and I always go to Barney's and I
usually spend three times what I'm making on whatever the talk show is.
And the talk show you get paid scale,
which is a,
I dunno,
what the fuck is it like 900 bucks.
So,
you know.
Yeah.
I Dunno if that lady who wrote it,
if you're listening,
if you wonder why I wear a suit and it's the host of the show is wearing a suit,
you know what I'm saying?
You dress for the room.
I'm not going to come out there and look like somebody they just pulled out of
the crowd.
You know,
it's funny,
I really have to explain this every fucking time.
I do.
I do the,
uh,
I do one of these late night talk shows.
I don't understand why people,
you know,
don't you notice when the actress come out,
they're all wearing suits.
They're all dressed up.
They wear a jacket,
you dress nice.
Women come out,
you know,
dressed to the nines,
I guess people who are characters and maybe whores.
Didn't Madonna come out with like no panties on one time or something?
Was that will Ferrell or he just came out wearing leather panties?
I can't fucking remember.
I,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
Um,
I love the suit and I love the shirt and uh,
you know,
I got quite a collection.
I think I've got like five or six of them.
Got a couple of navy blues.
I've got a nice brown one.
I got one other one.
I don't know what the fuck color it is.
And I said,
you know what,
I'm going to go with a nice charcoal gray this time,
you know,
and then get a shirt on underneath to make it pop bags,
zoom,
you know?
But evidently it was unbelievably,
unbelievably distracting.
Um,
Jesus Christ believing in autumn 22 minutes into this fucking podcast,
I was really worried that,
uh,
I wasn't gonna have enough shit this week because I'm,
I can't get on the Internet here in my hotel room.
Um,
all right,
so what can I talk about here to fucking flesh this out and give you a nice half
hour.
Got to give at least a half hour here.
Uh,
yeah.
So I'm in New York and I'm going to be doing,
um,
my next,
uh,
I think I got five or six more days shooting on this film and I'm,
I'm having the time of my life.
And,
uh,
even though I'm only shooting six days and I'm out here for a month,
I am going to go be going down to the set,
watching the other actors,
trying to learn that whole side of a,
of this business because,
uh,
I've obviously,
I don't know,
I've never done a big movie before and it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty,
it's pretty amazing.
It's pretty amazing.
So I'm trying to figure out,
um,
you know,
just go down there and watch the actors that know what the hell they're doing,
how they do different takes and they do all that type of stuff.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
It's pretty a pretty awesome time in my life.
It's the exact reason why I moved out to La.
I wanted to start getting bit parts in movies and,
um,
you know,
yeah.
And just keep doing standup and,
uh,
that's what the fuck I'm doing.
And uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck to tell you.
It's my birthday,
so I don't know what I'm going to do.
I wrote,
I'm going to do,
I've got a fucking workout.
I eat hay,
the worst God damn pizza last night here in New York.
I couldn't believe it.
I've had better pizza in La.
I ordered for one of those famous Ray's pizza places,
which,
you know,
aren't the best.
I know.
I'm going to get a ton of emails going or what do you,
out of your fucking mind?
Famous raised four constructs all with the,
you got to go down to Fuckin a with the fuck.
Is that place right off of,
uh,
sixth avenue down the village.
I know where that place is that literally Joe's pizza,
whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
I'm actually a fan of sudden pizza over on first avenue with just a couple of
blocks north of,
uh,
danger fields.
I Dunno why I like it.
There's something about their sauce.
Gives a nice little zing.
Oh.
And also I used to live up that way and that used to be my last spot of the
night.
Back in the day when I used to live in New York,
when,
uh,
they,
I guess nowadays they're booking the club's a month at a time,
but back in the day,
you know,
when I moved to New York in 1995 children,
um,
and they didn't have hybrid cars and they couldn't listen to your phone calls.
Um,
it was unbelievable to be a comedian,
to be a young,
young comic moving to New York City.
And um,
you basically on the weekend you could do anywhere from eight shows all the way
up to like maybe like 10 or 11.
Once you got up to 10,
it was pretty much pushing it.
And how you would do it is you would put your avails in with all the clubs
around the city.
And I used to work the comic strip,
that was the first club I got into and there was the Boston comedy club,
the comedy cellar stand up New York.
Um,
and then later on was danger fields
when I finally got into there.
And you just lead in each,
each club left,
you left your veils on different days.
So you could kind of set it up and you could just do a run all the way around
the city and you just leave avails a,
hey,
this is bill burr.
I'm leaving my avails for this weekend.
Just to let you know,
I got a nine 20 at the comic strip and I got an 1125 spot at stand up New York.
And then the seller would work around those spots.
Give you a couple more.
The Boston Comedy Club would give you a couple more and then you would just
start your night and you know,
you jump in a cab,
you do your spot,
you'd run out,
you grab a cab,
then you go down town,
backup town back downtown bay.
You know what the funny thing was is he ended up blowing and half you fucking
gig money on uh,
doing like a cab and all the comics.
You just be running around town doing spots and uh,
you know,
people,
sometimes your spots would be really close together and you'd call a buddy of
yours.
Do what time's your next spot?
Can you do me favor?
Can you do the 1125 and then I'll do your 1150 spot.
Can you do that just cause I have a,
all right man.
Okay.
I'll cover for you.
And it was just fucking amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
And like,
and then the end of the nine,
you get 50 bucks a spot,
cash and then the end of the night you just,
you'd have this big wad of cash in your pocket and you'd hang out with all your
other comedy friends,
you've comedian friends and you get a slice of pizza and then you just sit,
stand around.
You know,
it'd probably be like two in the morning,
two 30 in the morning,
you do your last spot and then you just stand around breaking balls until like
four or five in the morning as the sun's coming up.
And uh,
at that point I was actually living in an apartment with a Robert Kelly,
hilarious comedian,
one of my great friends in this business.
And,
uh,
I remember,
you know,
that was way back in the day and we become an home and the sun would be coming
up and everybody would be getting ready to go off to work.
And uh,
you just felt like you were getting away with murder.
It was literally the,
a standup comedy version of good fellas is the closest I ever felt like I was in
Goodfellas was when I would come home when the sun was coming up.
And,
uh,
you know,
that whole little,
uh,
narration where,
whatever ray Liotta talks about fucking what it was like to be in the mob,
how they didn't pay for Shit and all the regular people who went to work where a
bunch of saps,
that's literally what you felt like you decide everybody going to fucking work
and you're just like,
Eh,
I'm not,
I think I'm going to go fucking sleep till two in the afternoon,
get up,
play video games,
and then fucking do this all over again.
It was great.
It was a fucking great time in my life and I swear to God,
I still,
uh,
even with all the cool shit that I did this week,
I,
I swear to God,
it's like that part of my career that's,
it's still on par with everything that happened this week.
Uh,
I don't know.
Look at me.
I'm having a little touching podcast here.
A little file should add like little fucking a man is not a du Du du.
I left out a lot of shit,
like all the fucking psycho chicks I used to date and the chick who fucking
stocked me and all that type of stuff.
That was a fucking,
so it wasn't all good.
But you know what I mean?
You tend to Romanticize the shit when you're younger.
I'm actually sitting here right now looking at a picture of my dog,
Cleo,
and I can't tell you how much I missed that fucking dog.
I absolutely loved that dog.
It's ridiculous.
Fucking dog was not even in my life like a month ago.
And now,
like,
I'm already thinking about that.
You know,
someday the dog's going to die and how fucking awful I'm going to feel.
But,
uh,
it's a greatest fucking dog and the planet.
It's just,
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
And my girlfriend actually took it out over to a friend's house who also had a
dog and it's the first time it was off the leash and you know,
it's still a puppy.
So like a year and a half.
And I guess once it realized it was off the leash,
it was running around like a maniac,
Kevin,
the time of its life.
And I missed it and I was unbelievably depressed that I missed it.
I literally felt like I missed my firstborn taking his first steps and uh,
yeah,
I don't know what to tell you.
I fucking love that dog.
And if you're thinking about getting a dog,
if there's any way you can do what you gotta do it,
it's the greatest thing ever.
And go down to the pound and grab one dude,
they're free.
Fuck all this,
this rescuing shit.
I hate when people say that I rescued it.
Like you pulled it out of a fire.
You know,
you got it for free.
All right?
You're not a hero.
You're a cheap fuck.
Um,
now I know it's a great thing to do.
you know what you like?
You like a Ann landers there in that show,
that movie a dead man walking Susan Surandon.
That's her name.
You know,
that's what you like.
If you actually could have saved Sean Penn,
Uh,
but anyways,
I don't know what the fuck else to talk.
I'll tell you about,
I told you a lot of personal stories,
so I feel like I did my Goddamn job this weekend,
uh,
about those red sox.
Huh?
Ah,
his Raleigh Yankee fans are like,
ah,
you motherfucker,
you mother fucker.
I am a motherfucker.
All right.
And we've beat new six games in a row.
How does that feel?
How does that feel with your $400 million on three people?
Uh,
all Aga Burnett out there looking like he's in deliverance.
You know,
he looked like he should have been sitting outside of fucking gas station in the
forties in the south.
Why does,
in his uniform fit?
I want to send him a big long fucking email.
I really appreciate you serving up all those meatballs to the Red Sox,
but your uniform was so distracting.
You're from the Toronto Blue Jays.
You're a hockey loving fucking pubic haired mustache.
I don't know.
Um,
anyways,
I got a buddy of mine,
a comedian,
he's a big time fucking Yankee Fan and uh,
he keeps trying to get all excited about this team and I'm just like,
I just keep breaking his balls going to,
you guys spent four and a million dollars on three fucking guys.
You should be in first place.
There's no excitement when you spend that kind of fucking money,
you know?
That's what I can't stand about Yankee fans is they actually have the nerve to
get excited about the team that they bought.
You know,
it's obnoxious.
What you have is fucking obnoxious.
It's like,
it's like a bunch of ninth graders playing a bunch of third graders,
you know,
a GC to fork in yaggies.
Oh,
they fucking swept the royals over the,
yeah,
they spend 90 times what the fucking royal spent.
You know,
why don't you do with the Red Sox?
Do we add a couple of big time free agents?
Then you let your farm too.
Oh that's right.
You're not a good organization,
but you got a lot of money.
Look at you and yet,
Oh and six against the red sox.
You know,
that's got to hurt.
Hey,
I saw somebody do a thing,
a this when I was in a,
this is,
there's a,
there's a sports guy here in New York that I really like.
Uh,
he used to wear sweaters all the time.
I don't know what his name is.
He's got the white hair and he's got a really hardcore New York accent.
He's on TV and uh,
I don't know.
He,
he,
you know,
talk about a regular guy.
He really seems like a sports bar.
Like it Kinda guy hangs out in a sports bar.
You know,
when he'd sit around breaking balls and that type of shit.
But you know,
he's on TV wearing a suit.
Why do you think that his sweetheart maybe cause he's on TV.
He wants to look presentable.
I forget the guy's name,
but I really like him.
You know,
he's like Yankees were up in Boston and they didn't do nothing.
He literally talks like that.
He's fucking great.
But uh,
he was talking about,
you know,
what's the biggest rivalry in sports and people keep saying the Yankees,
red sox and uh,
I dunno,
I dunno if it is anymore.
You know,
it's weird.
It's weird.
Somebody was trying to say,
and it ended in 2004 but you know what's funny was people used to say before
2004 like,
dude,
this isn't even a rivalry.
A rivalry is when you've got two evenly matched teams for the most part.
And they go back and forth.
And I could definitely tell you before 2004 we did not go back and forth.
We got our asses handed to us.
So now it actually is a rivalry because we do go back and forth.
But the weird fucking thing is it was all about breaking the curse.
And now that we did it,
you know,
dad,
86 years of,
of Shit talk and hanging over your head to be lifted.
I don't know.
It's,
it's really not the same thing.
I was talking to a buddy of mine about that last night on the phone and uh,
I dunno,
I think the after seen on Hbo,
I saw this thing about the Ohio state Buckeye,
Michigan Wolverine rivalry and I challenge any Yankee or red sox fan to watch
that thing and t and you and to act as though fucking red sox Yankees is at that
level.
Cause I got news for you.
It isn't,
those people are fucking maniacs out there.
I actually went to a Michigan,
Ohio state game.
How great is my fucking life to hell was I doing,
I was doing some sort of road gig and I,
I got some,
I got tickets to it.
This is back on.
The only guy I can really remember was playing was that wide receiver a Boston
for uh,
Ohio state was playing.
It was the late nineties.
And um,
I don't fucking know.
All I know is I've never been to a sporting of 100,000,
like 105,000 people showed up,
hundred and five fucking thousand people.
And there was like another 30,000 people outside trying to buy tickets.
I,
you know,
the only other thing I've seen bigger than that as the Indianapolis 500,
which I don't know how many people that fucking holds,
but I mean
you're talking about cars going 200 miles an hour.
So,
and there's people surrounding the entire thing.
Um,
I kind of lost track there.
I don't know what the fuck I'm trying to say.
Every time that time I went to fucking a the Indianapolis 500,
it's a fucking great time.
You can bring
your own booze in there.
You bring it,
you get,
you get low.
This is what you do.
You just buy as much fucking beer as humanly possible.
Don't get hard stuff cause you're going to pass out by the fi halfway through
the race,
right?
And you're going to hit by some debris,
but you bring a fucking cooler in there and it's all these fucking crazy redneck
fans.
And uh,
you know,
the car's just go flying by.
He can't really see shit.
All you do is hope that somebody crashes in front of you.
And then when they do,
they hit the wall and then they just keep fucking going.
It's not like they hit the wall and just stop,
you know they hit the wall.
It's just,
it's like a fucking cartoon and that's all you hear.
You just stand there and you just hear him coming around the corner just here.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that she is usually either the first guy,
the last guy and then at their kind of bunched together.
You just here
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it's pretty good,
right?
Cause I fucking heard it for about fuck God damn hours getting shit faced and
there's nothing to do.
So what you do is you go in there and I dunno,
there's like 40 cars or something like that,
that race and everybody just starts gambling,
right?
And if you're there with four other guys each,
he gets 10 fucking cars and everybody throws in a 100 bucks and then you just
start looking for you guys,
right?
And all of a sudden they're going around next time to come back around.
You notice one of you guys is a day like what the fuck happened to him?
And then you're like,
ah,
God damn it,
he hit the wall.
Shit,
I'm down to nine guys.
It actually,
it actually stays interesting.
I went two years in a row.
I went in [inaudible] 95 and in [inaudible] 96 and uh,
I definitely recommend it.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about here.
People I don't even know,
I don't have my fucking computers on because I'm in this hotel and I can't sign
up for the Goddamn,
uh,
the Internet.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I'm going to be in New York for a month and I'm going to be popping around the
clubs doing spots.
Um,
I haven't left avails yet,
but if you're in the New York City area and you want to watch me and a bunch of
other great comics,
I'll probably be going up down the seller,
maybe the comic strip,
Caroline's,
I'll probably pop into a Gotham,
all these fucking places and uh,
I'll be doing 10 minutes,
try out some new shit and um,
I'll be in a great mood because,
uh,
that's what I always find.
There's this euphoria after you do one of those late night talk shows,
because you got to do what you got the rush of doing it and it went well and the
pressure of doing it is lifted and uh,
you know,
and then it's your birthday and you're like,
I'm going to go buy a fucking slice,
a red velvet cake.
That's what I'm going to do,
you know?
[inaudible] and stick a candle in it and just singing happy birthday to myself
and just see if anybody else in the restaurant either joins in or if they just
look at me like I'm a complete psycho.
I wish I had the acting chops to start singing that to myself and then actually
breaking down crying.
I want if I would,
uh,
fuck.
Alright.
So that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast I did here on Wednesday.
Sorry,
it took me a couple of days,
but I had a big week and a,
sorry about the production value of a,
the podcast isn't going to be that good,
uh,
over the next couple of weeks as I hang in here in New York.
And that said,
I hope all you guys have a great week and a,
and that is it.
And a happy birthday to me.
All right.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
spoke to problem
number one.